good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have something special that when you
unleash it it will be able to change the
world so to help you on your journey
today's messages outwork the competition
over to you Dwayne the rock Johnson well
yes I get up at crazy hours whether it's
3 o'clock in the morning by the way when
we're talking in London I was getting up
at 3:00 because I had to be on set by
4:00 I'm sorry by 7:00 so whatever time
my call time is and I tell this to
Studios and directors and our producers
whatever time I call time so my call
time is at 7 then you back your clock up
for hours and then that's when I get out
and train twice I'll get my cardio in
and breakfast and then I'll go hit the
weights clanging and banging we call it
Jack and the iron but like what time do
you go to bed I mean you might shoot
really late at night I'm averaging on a
movie on average probably about five
hours of sleep all right
empty gym the way we'd like it it's
Sunday just finish my warmup it is
family day it's the Lord's Day it is
also like that so it was paying on
respondents up to seven all right
Saturday afternoon empty gym the way we
like it
tripping over here it's late day which
means
sweaty painful and fun
[Music]
don't get it
but war left
one more come on oh good focus
all right workout number two I'm out
working all my competition tired after
gym what we like it getting ready to get
after me and my favorite training
partner bring it home let's bring it out
so I love the rock I love his drive I
love his motivation love his ambition I
love his work ethic there are two things
that I took from this video clip one is
you have to find the work that you love
if you look at the rock you watch the
video he's working out Saturday he's
working out Sunday he loves it when the
gym is empty he's out working his
competition and that's incredibly
motivational to watch and you see him
lifting the weights and it gets you
pumped up but you should be doing the
same thing in your business like it
doesn't mean you have to go and workout
on a Saturday morning but you should
have that same level of care attention
to detail love passion that he has for
working out in your business right and
so if I look at what I do I look at my
youtube channel every day I look at the
comments I looked at the stats I look at
the videos I look at the reactions that
are coming in I look at TDS stuff every
day I look at what lily is working on I
look at my website like I love the stuff
that I'm doing where if it's a Saturday
morning and I'm waking up and yes I'm
spending time with Haden and yes I'm
spending time with Nina and yes we're
doing family activities and barbecues
and that kind of stuff and I'm not
spending as much time on a weekend as I
am during the week on my business and
the grind and everything I'm doing there
but I'm still I'm it doesn't feel like
work like I want to know what you guys
are saying I want to know what the
comments are coming I'm looking forward
to the life-changing comment every
morning that comes in I want to know how
well this new video series that we put
up is doing I want to know how well TDS
is doing I want to know how well that
classy poster is doing did that
marketing technique work versus that
technique or that slogan versus that
slogan like how is everything working I
want to know it fuels me it gets me
excited it's not work it's not waking up
on Saturday like ah I got a check my
stupid YouTube comments these people
write like it's not like that I love it
and so it's finding that thing that you
love doing and this is a consistent
message across every
pretty much that we've profiled you have
to love the work so that waking up on a
Saturday to go and do this thing
whatever it is acting working out doing
SEO making videos whatever it is you
look forward to it you want to do it
you're happy that you're there you're
not complaining that you should be at
this barbecue or you should be sleeping
in or you should be going to watch that
baseball game or whatever it is because
you enjoy the work of what could do in
and so having that level of commitment
and passion to the craft that you are
focused on I think is really really
important to have success in any field
the second thing that I really took from
this video is the importance of the
morning routine and what I found really
interesting was how he would if he's on
shoot and he knows he needs X number of
hours he would wake up those number of
hours early to then make sure he does
his morning routine and being fanatical
about keeping that morning routine and
I'm a big believer in having a morning
routine I think it really sets you up a
success if you find the thing that makes
you feel bold and confident and alive
and excited and put that into your
morning routine then you're much more
likely to have an amazing day instead of
randomly hope when you get inspired
throughout the day most people fall out
of the bed and just do a couple things
and then they're off to work kind of
going through the motions as opposed to
having designed a morning routine to
really support you for me I find myself
if I get distracted I fall off of the
morning routine I fall off my schedule
and so the key for me traditionally has
been to eliminate distractions that's
why I don't use a cell phone so I have a
rigid schedule it's why I don't have a
number that you can call me on it's why
you know I have certain days for
different things but if I'm traveling or
if something else is kind of falling off
I'm committed somewhere that's a little
strange for me it's not part of my usual
routine then I don't do my morning
routine or I'm not as consistent with it
and so that's an area that I could be
better at I think even today I watched
the the rock video yesterday and so
today I did today is filming day for me
so I'm coming in with to be here at 8:30
we start filming and we're gonna make
you know 6070 videos today and
if I woke up what I normally woke up
then I wouldn't have time to do my
morning routine so I woke up earlier
today woke up a little bit earlier I
went through everything I normally do in
our morning routine I feel great I'm
here ready to record for you this is a
weird day for me because this happens
once a month it throws off my schedule
and so I think that strategy of trying
to eliminate distractions eliminate
schedule changes can really help it
really adds a lot of value to me and on
90% of the days it works because I don't
have distractions I've eliminated them
from them my team knows not that
distracting unless it's really important
you know cut out all of the things that
we're taking attention away from me
being a focus what I'm doing
but for those 10% of the days it's an
interesting strategy when something
unexpected happens or when I'm traveling
or when I have to wake up to come to do
this or something like that the idea of
waking up earlier and making that
morning routine an absolute must 100
percent of the time and something I'm
gonna take away and maybe apply them
live we'll see how it works out so the
question of the day today is I'm curious
what is the most important thing from
your morning routine the thing that you
know if you did every single day you
would set yourself up for an amazing day
what is the one most important part of
your morning routine I'd love to hear
from you
leave it down in the comments below I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Michael Johnson Michael thank you so
much you're picking up a copy of my book
your one-word and post in the picture on
Instagram I love the smile thank you so
much for the support I really appreciate
it and I'm so glad you enjoyed the read
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love and I'll see you
guys again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso
let's pray so give me go
choice you have as an underdog is if
you're gonna choose to fight and choose
to fight to win there are a series of
strategies available to you but they are
all more costly than the strategies
available to the favorite so I give the
example I'll have a chapter about a and
a software mogul in Silicon Valley an
Indian guy who coaches his daughter's 12
year old daughter's basketball team and
they are without talent they are by his
own by his own admission this was like
they didn't know how to barely know how
to play the game it takes them all the
way to the national championships he
does it by he instructs them they're
gonna play the full-court press every
minute of every game and defend every
inch of the court right now that's
actually a very effective strategy
particularly in h-class basketball if
you're the underdog
it's your Liron chance of winning is to
play a really really aggressive defense
it requires however that everyone in
your team expend maximum effort every
minute of the game you cannot loaf for
an instant you have to be in really good
shape and you have to run yourself
ragged and you cannot let up most people
will not play that way because it's too
difficult if I said to you we're not
going to be doing does this elegantly
designed plays and shooting gorgeous
baskets and passing the ball we're just
going to be doing this for the entire
game and you're gonna be exhausted at
the end most kids would say that that's
not why I signed up so it's like that's
a kind of classic illustration of that
effort effort is the route one of the
routes available to the underdog I can
outwork you even if I may not be able to
outspend you but I can outwork you well
how working is a tall order it's not
easy to do you know that's as anyone who
has worked in a start-up knows that's
this one of the stressful parts of it
but successful startups I am I've never
seen any actual data on this but do we
think the people working for
successful startups work longer hours
than people who work for fortune 500
companies but when you look at the
business that you're in
do you find that your hustle and your
ability to outwork helps absolutely
absolutely I mean when I say that this
business and I learned this from Luther
Campbell from to live cool ice you know
one of the first guys I did a record
deal with and he always said that it's
90% business 10% talent and if you see
that in the most the ones are the most
talented or the hardest to either get in
the studio or the ones that they get up
on stage and they don't know if they're
gonna hit the right note right and do
this right and don't worry about it as
opportunities are the next thing is I
would say the hard work hard work is
really really important to be successful
and to be at the top like 10% of the
population in terms of success all those
people who work their ass off you're not
going to be successful without hard work
and the reason mostly is not even they
have to go out there and and build a
giant Empire or you have to a mass
amount of money or work long hours it's
not even so much about that it's that
you need to develop yourself because
success is not so much an outer world
state as an inner world state and that
might sound kind of hokey and New Age
but it's very very true success is
grounded within you you're not gonna be
able to maintain any sort of level of
success if you do not have the
psychology to really follow principles
to know how to maintain success to think
strategically to think long term to
delay gratification to resist
addictions all these factors come into
play
so really for me success is grounded in
self mastery it's understanding yourself
and then building on that building
disciplines building successful habits
which then move you towards where you
want to be going